it's a great pleasure to be here at
toughest this is a great event and we
kicked off with an amazing keynote and I
couldn't be happier to be here in this
event and where we talk about making a
difference and maybe a little bit
related to the theme today what I'm
gonna talk about is contributing to
making a difference in a
underrepresented part of the society I
hope this is gonna be a fun talk I will
try my best to make it as enjoyable as
possible there are a lot of new tech
involved and making a difference let's
start with the boring bits this is the
the usual introduction slide I'm Armand
I'm jyler that's the correct
pronunciation of my name I come from
Berlin here in Germany I work for a
company called uno again Baja and I
serve as the head of software
engineering there what we do is we build
electric scooters electric motorcycles
much like west pop but with batteries
and then we are also inventing tools for
the future of mobility and urban
mobility I'm also a founder of something
called lounger works which is a software
craftsmanship school for women that is
completely voluntary because we have a
huge gap to close for the between
between different genders and we try to
help the West we can i'm also active on
github i have a lot of open-source
libraries from front and libraries to
beckon libraries to brain signal
processing and making music with the
browser most of them are in javascript
almost 90% of them are in javascript
it's all open source i like everything i
have written in my personal career is
open source so if you are interested in
any of these topics you can check out my
get up before we start i'm also a little
bit a little bit under the weather
i-i had a flu for the past two weeks so
if I cough during the the presentation I
apologize for that
I don't want to irritate your ears but I
yeah sometimes I might need that so the
question is very very simple the
question is what is the ultimate hack of
our lives and this came into my
imagination while I was attending a a
meet-up in Berlin and that was called
Berlin HEC and Tel so hackers around
Berlin and other other cities got
together they do it every month at the
at the end of the month and they present
their hacks and these are not like
software software hacks where you hack a
web page or something these are like
real life hacks that you use a device or
a technology out of its context out of
his purpose and I was participating for
two times in a row with different
projects and I was very fortunate enough
to win the title of the best hack of the
month two times in a row and then for
the third time I thought if I win it
again they would give me a cup you know
like the World Cup if you win it three
times you get to keep it because there
was a trophy that they were giving
giving out and then you take it back
every month and the question was like
you know what can I do more to impress
these amazing people these amazing
hackers what is the the ultimate hack
and while I look no further than that
myself and then my brain in fact I had
the idea that maybe maybe we can do
something with the brain we can type
with the brain now obviously this idea
is not new it's been around for a very
very long time and I think last year or
maybe the year before
Elon Musk came up with the idea of a new
company in neuro-link and what they do
is they build a high-speed highway
between your brain and a computer so
they are building brain computer
interfaces or human machine interaction
devices and what they aim is to have to
open your skull and put some electrodes
there that will transmit wirelessly your
thoughts to a
pewter or your phone so that you can
type or communicate with your brain
signals and he had this code I think
we're about 8 to 10 years away from this
being usable by people with no
disability and I'm gonna talk a little
bit more about that in a few minutes but
you know Elon Musk is a great great guy
but here's a little bit optimistic about
everything in the deliverables as well
and this is not gonna this is not gonna
work in 8 to 10 years in fact this field
is being tackled for the past 30 years
now it's hard in 1988 and we still have
like 20 30 or maybe 50 years to make
this work with real people with people
with no disability there's a distinction
between people with disabilities and not
able-bodied people obviously it's a lot
straightforward we treat able-bodied
people like mice lab mice because you
know they respond perfectly to whatever
you give to them so we do the research
on them but in fact the actual target is
disabled people so if you have ALS if
you have locked-in syndrome and if you
cannot move your arm or eyes or or any
muscle in fact you still deserve to
communicate with the outer world because
you can think there is nothing wrong
with your brain in your mind other than
that your body is paralyzed so it's it
has its own difficulties and challenges
working with people with disabilities in
this context but the end goal is to make
this a part of everybody's lives
especially people with disabilities so
that they can you know they are back
back in the game so Facebook also made
an announcement right after that I think
one or two months after that after Elon
Musk and they said we're also working on
brain computer interfaces and they said
our goal is to build a brain computer
interface that lets you type
to your mobile phone you don't dictate
with your voice you just think and
you're gonna be able to type much faster
than you can physically type with your
fingers so this is like a superhuman
ability or this is gonna be and she was
a little bit realistic she said this is
gonna be there in 20 years so we're just
kicking off and you know it's it's some
future technology so bear with us we'll
take some time to make this a reality
now this is a picture from I guess eight
years ago from 2010 this is me in the
picture if you couldn't identify right
now and this is my assistant now I'm
kidding she is she was my best friend
she is - my best best friend and she was
helping me out with this experiment this
is right before a live broadcast where I
demonstrated a brain computer interface
where I typed with my brain signals in
real time on TV and I was getting ready
for for that and this was eight years
ago
so this tweet is from January 6 2010 and
I typed it with my brain signals Oh
with all those Smiley's and and
everything and I tweeted with my brain
signals so no motor neurons involved or
no muscles involved in the making of
this tweet and it's still there I think
in my profile so if you go way back
eight years back you can see that this
technology is actually reality right now
and I'm here today to talk about how we
do this with JavaScript because that is
the hack part of it right it's great to
be able to type something from your
brain but it's even cooler if you can do
it with only JavaScript and and nothing
else obviously this was part of my
master's thesis back at the University
and I was using MATLAB C++ C and C sharp
all together to make this happen
writing low-level drivers for EEG
headsets and the UI in in c-sharp that
wasn't a good experience and all the
classification algorithms we call them
machine learning algorithms right now
but that's a fancy name so all the
classification algorithms were in MATLAB
and it worked really good you can type
up to 20 to 25 characters per minute so
it's like every two three seconds you
can type a single letter and if you
think this thing works with locked-in
patients it's the world of a difference
for them you know one one day you have
no ability to to communicate with your
loved ones and the the other day you can
type like one letter or one symbol like
an emoji as well in a few seconds that's
that's a huge huge difference and that's
why I picked up this topic again so a
little bit introduction on EEG raise
your hands if you know what EEG is a lot
of people that's great
raise your hands if you ever saw an EEG
recording like this okay great
EEG means electroencephalography so the
basic idea is we have electrodes on your
scalp and they track the electrical
activity in your brain or on your skull
not in your brain obviously this is a
non-invasive operation so that we don't
delve into our brain but we gather
whatever we can from your scalp hence
that's why I'm I'm bald because it works
best
you know life sometimes has this push a
little help like when you want to do
research about brain signals life takes
away your hair from you and this is a
perfect match so this is one of the
earliest easy recordings in history
that's done by a German scientist called
Hans Berger I'm not making the name up I
know that's the most common German name
Hans and Berger but it's a very real
name of a very well known scientist in
in Germany in 1924 so he was he had the
idea that the brain is very powerful so
maybe we can record electricity out of
it
he came up with this experiment and this
is one of the earliest recordings of
brain signals however the scientific
community mocked him they shot him out
and they like nobody believed them for
about ten years he was struggling with
this he lost all of his credibility in
in the scientific community but after 10
years some people were able to replicate
his results and his experiments that you
know some people have different
electrical activity in their brain and
then they restored his his career but
this is what happens to very early
people if you are an innovator like this
you you face the risk of being mocked
but he persisted on and the the story is
a happy ending story and he was you know
he is the founder of this whole EEG
thing and now you know we treat millions
of patient patients every year with this
technology so it's it's a groundbreaking
thing but one thing you'll notice here
is that obviously the resolution of the
data is not that interesting it's almost
like a science wave both on the on the
bottom and on the top as well and
obviously the equipment of the past was
unable to gather high frequency high
quality data from the brain it was still
useful though this was still useful and
nowadays we have huge improvements in
technology and also we digitalized
obviously everything and what this means
is we now get very quality signal out of
the brain and right now it almost looks
like noise if you ever saw audio noise
it almost looks like noise because it
includes your brain signals plus all the
electrical and magnetic noise around you
therefore the best experiments are done
in something called a Faraday cage raise
our hands if you know what a fire that
cage is yeah so it's completely isolated
magnetically so even God can't see you
inside
and there are no no interceptions from
any mobile signal wireless signal radio
signal whatever and you and your brain
signals only and that is the safest
place to run these experiments but yeah
so it's very very high quality
you know like 96 kilohertz sampling
rates which is really high for brain
signals which are from zero or one Hertz
to maybe thirty Hertz so we have a lot
of signals that we have that we can work
with and the challenge is actually huge
but hopefully I will be able to
demonstrate how this thing works in
JavaScript so I built a node application
an electron application for this and
let's see if it's going to work
it might not yeah it does that because
that's how live demos go right most of
the time it just doesn't work so this is
me sitting in my home with the same
headset the same laptop and I'm
demonstrating how the the typing
actually works do you do you wonder how
it works is this interesting to you
thank you so there's a countdown and
basically what I do is I just stare at
the screen and the computer knows what I
want to type here I'm trying to type a
message hello that's the first word in
hello world so that's also in on my
Twitter profile if you go to my Twitter
profile it's the pin tweet so you can
watch this attribute so I just stare at
the screen there are letters there these
if you cannot up oh oh that was the
wrong button
let's skip forward yeah if you cannot
identify them these are letters of the
alphabet and they are flashing they are
randomly flashing and I want to type one
single letter I think I now want to type
E and I'm looking at E okay
and whenever e flashes I'm counting it
internally oh sorry this is still the H
and let's do the exercise so I'm looking
at E right now and whenever it flashes
I'm gonna count 1 2 3 and so on and so
forth and after a certain amount of data
being gathered the system knows that you
are being excited about a single letter
and that's e and all the other letters
when they're flashing they don't mean a
thing to you so obviously I mentioned
the quality of this headset and and that
it's a consumer grade headset that's why
it takes significant amount of time to
come up with the letter but you have you
can run any any machine learning
algorithm or any classifier transfer
flow or whatever you want in order to
identify these patterns all of these
brain signals so it's actually very
simple and kind of a boring watch so I
just look at the screen and I cannot
move I'm not allowed to move because
again this headset uses contact lens
solution have you ever tasted it the
contact best cleaning solution raise
your hands if you ever tasted it yeah
one super perfect yeah we yes I love you
of course I did because you know it
looks like water right that has to be
something special in what is it it has
some salt in it it's a salty solution
saline solution we call it and that's
the perfect thing for this headset
because it increases the the
transmission of electrodes
electrons from your skull scalp - to the
electrodes so you just wet the the pads
here the electrodes put it on your hair
or your bald head and then you get nice
signals obviously in real life in the
hospitals or in actual research we use
gels that are very sticky and there is
there are really hard to get out of your
your hair hence I had to use myself as a
research subject when I was doing this
research but sorry but the idea is that
if you move your head obviously there is
no strong connection between the
electrodes and and your head and these
signals are on the order of micro volts
like 10 micro volt 20 micro volts that's
very very small and when you move your
head the muscles come into play
and obviously oh yeah yes I was able to
type hello and yeah I then right away
posted this on on Twitter of course
because why not but if you move your
head what you see is in fact there is a
lot of noise both due to your own
movement and the movement of the
electrodes it's it's it's actually a
very yeah I mean you can imagine the the
level of excitement that I had right it
was huge
so let's how do I move forward yeah
alright so how does this black magic
work what is the underlying mechanism
for this thing now we have a hundred
billion neurons in our brains a hundred
billion neurons it's like the number of
galaxies in the universe it's a lot it's
a huge number and currently I have 14
electrodes on my scalp and the best
devices that are external that are
non-invasive have like 256
electrodes which leaves you with four
hundred thousand neurons per electrode
okay which means we actually don't know
what's going on in your brain we have no
idea what we get is a single electrical
lead that gives you the sum of four
hundred thousand different neurons
firing in different directions and the
worst part is these electrical signals
are vectors we're at a university so I
can maybe talk a little bit about math
these are vectors that have an amplitude
and a direction so one neuron is firing
this way okay the other neuron is firing
this way when you sum them up what you
get zero right so imagine how many
neurons fire in all the ways of four
hundred thousand neurons and what you
end up with is you know mostly zero you
don't really get a lot of signals
obviously in certain situations you get
certain signals but it's really really
hard to to get quality quality signals
from the brain but obviously if we could
if we had a way to go inside your brain
and to implant electrodes there we could
even read your dreams in fact there is
research being done for this even with
external high-resolution electrodes we
can read what people see so it's like a
live feed of what you see because all
you see actually is information that's
been transferred to your brain and it's
processed on the back of your skull and
by just reading there we can see what
you see obviously very very low
resolution but research is being done on
this ok so there are some chemical
reactions of potassium and sodium that
exchange
well one neuron exchanges for su and the
other ones your sodium and then there is
a potential difference which basically
means voltage there's a
difference and this is what we measure
from the from the brain now if you open
the skull you can with the consent of
the person of their family of their
Hospital and of the government because
the the patient has to be terminally ill
because the probability of losing the
patient is really high if you open their
skull and implant electrodes some people
receive it very well some of the brains
just reject the electrodes and terrible
things can happen that's why this is not
gonna happen in the next 8 to 10 years
maybe it's gonna take 50 years to get
all the governments on board and to make
this technology a safe technology to
operate but if you can do that then you
can implant thousands of electrodes
inside the brain then you have a lot
more visibility in the actual firings of
not individual neurons obviously because
nobody can use 100 billion electrodes
but at least a little bit more
resolution but the the underlying idea
is unfortunately we just don't know how
it works and that is the that is the
worst worst bit about this ok so what I
just showed you on the video is
something called a p300 signal and it's
called the oddball paradigm why the
oddball paradigm because I have 35
different letters that I'm not
interested in I'm only interested in one
symbol or one letter and that is odd you
know the probability of that flashing is
very tiny with respect to the other ones
and therefore the name is the oddball
paradigm and this has been first
published about in 1988 thirty years ago
by Immanuel dungeon they were able to
write or type 2.3 liters per minute and
then you know we were able to expand
this to further 10 letters 20 letters
and and further so I already talked
about how this thing works it works
based
randomly flashing letters in a matrix
and what you see is that there is an
action potential 300 milliseconds after
you see the letter flashing and you are
excited by it if you look at the graph
in the black in the black one you see
the actual signal that we're interested
in and if you can read it after 0.3
seconds 300 milliseconds of the original
signal you see a peak in the signal in
the black signal that is what gives us
this notion of yes this is what the
person is looking at so this is what
they actually want to tell you gather
hundreds of these and and refine your
judgement about what letter that they
what letter they want to type the thing
is the red one is the other signal or at
the regular signals so if you can
separate the black from the red you can
do this task it's it doesn't look like
really hard because there is a certain
difference in between these signals but
obviously these are refined these are
averages of again about 50 to 100
different signals from both for the
black and the red groups usually what
you see is the difference is not so
clear sometimes you just focus on a
different letter because your attention
just diverges and you know you get a lot
of false positives false negatives and
it's the the machine learning task to
make sure you can separate these black
from red so how do you start with
JavaScript any JavaScript developers
here please raise your hands okay it's
okay to admit if you are a JavaScript
developer I mean I have a proud
JavaScript developer and I'm here to
prove to the world that JavaScript can
do anything desktop mobile applications
and brain signal applications although
it didn't work previously because of the
headset raise our hands if you know
JavaScript you don't have to yeah all
right so everybody can read this code
right it's actually very straightforward
in in plain language constant mind
requires with
then you do mind open and open your mind
and then you read your mind to to the
console now let's see if this thing is
sorry
it's gonna work because looks like I
have connection yeah so these are the
real-time brain signals thank you
obviously you cannot discern what the
individual signals mean and you get a
lot of muscle movements when I'm talking
when I'm speaking or when I'm moving
even when I'm moving my hands so it's
pretty much all the information is
invisible to the eye but there is only
two types of information that you can
see with your eyes and that is for
example when I'm blinking and now let me
do it so you see the peaks right 1 2 3
the peaks there are the cause of the
blinks my eye blinks and in fact there
are no different brain signals there are
your muscle signals because I have a lot
of electrodes around my eye here now
there are a huge ton of misinformation
or this information about this online
people claim that it's easy to read
brain signals and and they do all sorts
of things with their brain signals but
what they usually do is they use the
muscles and muscle signals because they
are at least an order of magnitude
bigger or higher than than actual brain
signals so again when I blink my eye
that is what you see and that's mostly
through my muscles and I can play with
my jaw
and again I'm moving a lot of muscles on
my face and these are all muscle moments
these don't contain much brain signals
or or information in your brain signals
okay I'm glad that this time I worked
let's maybe move on to the other one so
I'm gonna type Const minds require wits
right mind that open and mind that we'd
console.log now hopefully when I run
this what you see is yeah here it is
basically a Jason log of your brain so
thank you so what you have is the the
battery percentage the counter numbers
so you can track each frame contact
quality in an arbitrary fashion the gyro
so you can also track your head movement
and the levels of each electrode that's
present in the system obviously these
are just numbers so if you know how to
work with numbers you can do anything
with your brain signals and yeah this is
an infinite infinite loop of brain
signals and every seven milliseconds
it's like 128 Hertz every second every 7
milliseconds you get one signal or one
reading from your brain and it's up to
you to aggregate them and make them make
them work
I wrote AC driver for the headset but
then everything else is in JavaScript so
no J's binding bindings and then
basically all sorry all the operation is
in JavaScript there is another oh by the
way this this tool is open source so if
you want to check the source code fork
or contribute to it or welcome there is
another one called brain monitor that is
like a command line monitor just like
this I mean the same thing in your
command line let's see if it's gonna
work
so you just like brain monitor and yeah
it does and you see the peaks there this
is running in your command line you can
run this in in whatever machine you like
in the cloud as well if you like so but
yeah you can upload your brain to the
cloud right all those buzz all those
buzz words that don't mean anything but
you can see the gyro on the top right
corner and when I move my head hopefully
you'll see the action replicated there
so if you want to do you know Mouse
tracking with your head or something and
your brain signals you know clicks with
the eye blinks you can you can do those
type of demos in fact the the quality is
kind of not not bad right now all right
let's go back to the presentation and
the last one is the brain bits this is
the application that lets you type with
your brain signals that are demoed in
the video it's also open source
everything again is in JavaScript it's
called a p300 speller because it makes
use of these p300 waves or signals in
your brain and it still needs a lot of
help especially with the machine
learning algorithm so if you are into
machine learning please lend a hand
I plan to port it to tensorflow
Jess and and make use of it so maybe if
somebody wants to contribute I'm open
for contributions ok the tech stack is
JavaScript all the way up this thing
didn't have native drivers so I had to
write some native C add-ons for the
headset to make it talk to JavaScript
but then node.js is doing the processing
all the machine learning algorithm is
running on on node.js in real time in
fact we use the electron as the wrapper
for the desktop application because you
can ship this as a desktop application
and of course obviously you can also put
it as a webpage and have something like
a WebSockets or something I use VJs on
the front end anybody uses vue.js
only a few people yeah it's really easy
it's it's a very very
purpose-built fast front-end framework
and all the lines that are being thrown
are done with mu J's I use brain dot j s
that was an existing library for neural
networks and basically you can swap in
any algorithm that you want you can use
neural networks or I use my own
classifier from ten years ago that I
wrote in MATLAB it's a custom Bayesian
linear discriminant analysis something
like that it's called payors in linear
discriminant analysis and it's the
classifier that's that I showed in the
demo that is again optimized for for
this brain task and I had to port it
from MATLAB right anybody knows MATLAB
raise your hands perfect one single
character like the star character for
matrix multiplication in MATLAB is like
a thousand lines in JavaScript I had to
write a lot of JavaScript forming
transforming all those functions of
matrix transposition and and eigen
vectors and everything and had to write
or find alternatives in JavaScript but I
did it worked and unfortunately I
couldn't find a very good function to
give me the the eigenvalue of of a piece
of data and I still use MATLAB for it I
built a web server in MATLAB to serve
the eigen eigen function so I function
so all the processing all the data
crunching is in JavaScript and there are
no web service and MATLAB has the web
server so it's the the roles are
switched between JavaScript and node.js
and MATLAB and it's serving one single
function if you don't have MATLAB on
your computers that's fine
you don't have to it's a it's a very
expensive purchase then you can use the
JavaScript fallback which is not that
performant all right so what do we do we
get to roll electrode data that looks
like noise and if you remember the graph
that I showed you earlier it's a section
of 1 seconds after the slash so after we
flash each letter we take one single
second we
called an epoch and we tried to look for
a peak right after 300 milliseconds but
obviously the brain has a lot of
information of a lot of different
frequencies so we have to filter them
out especially the low and the high
frequencies so we get a specific
bandwidth of frequencies that we are
looking for we then cut the outliers out
by a process called Vince realization so
the top 5% and low 5% are kicked out by
the way I'm telling you the secrets of
my research which is publicly published
anyway but nobody wants to read 150
pages of math right but if you implement
this algorithm you can already start
typing with your brain signals and then
we normalize data because obviously the
amplitude of each electron is different
from time to time it changes and you
have to identify what the peak is right
maybe you see a peak but the actual
amplitude is very small maybe it's just
noise so you have to make sure you are
actually looking at the brain signal and
not a radio cell tower or something
so we normalize data and then we do
something called decimation we don't
need that that many that many samples to
decide actually does anybody know the in
equus theorem Nyquist theorem a few
people all right
tell me please if we are interested in
the signals between 1 and 12 Hertz how
many samples do we need to be able to
faithfully reproduce the signal of two
offered smacks 24 yes because it's like
a sine wave you need an endpoint and a
start point to actually or a midpoint to
actually be able to figure out a sine
wave so at the minimum you need 24
samples if you are interested in 12
Hertz I know this is a little bit
technical but please don't let me lose
you
yeah so you remove most of the samples
because nobody can crunch that metadata
not even MATLAB and then you apply
machine learning you use either neural
networks or custom algorithms whatever
you wish to identify the red and the
black black signals right alright so the
conclusion is people say JavaScript is
powerful when it comes to reading JSON
API when it comes to consuming Jason
api's and what I claim is its yes it is
powerful enough to read and parse JSON
API is but it's also powerful to read
and parse your brains API so this is a
demonstration of that work and I kind of
open sourced the path into our brains
and now I'm looking for contributors to
make brain bits or JavaScript shine
again please raise your hands if I were
able to change your minds about
JavaScript okay a few people that's good
I call it a win this is this is a good
day cool yeah because I claim JavaScript
can't do anything I also do music with
it but that's that's the topic of
another talk so thank you for coming
today and if we have any time I think we
can have some questions yeah a few
little minutes and I might have a
another demo later in the day at una
boot if you come you can see me using my
brain signals to use the force in in
Star Wars it's very dangerous so I
didn't want to do it here but I'm gonna
try to use the force with my brain
signals later so if you have any
questions maybe one or two questions I
can have them anybody know oh there's
one
cool
yeah the question is can you actually
buy a hardware like this like can
anybody buy it do you need ID
verification to buy this hardware no you
don't need IDs for guns in the u.s. at
least so you don't need that used to buy
this it's publicly available this is a
consumer-grade hardware it's about I
don't know like seven hundred eight
hundred dollars and if you can shell out
that money you can do brain research at
home obviously there are more
professional level hardware that you
still can buy as individuals but they
would cost you around $20,000 so not
that easy
only the labs can afford it but yeah if
as an individual you're interested in it
there are a lot of cheaper models as
well but the one that I'm using is kind
of the closest to a research grade
hardware that lets you do all of these
stuff the others are just toys so yeah
this is publicly available and and you
can you can get onboard any other
questions
there's another one or there please
I think I think it's okay
and if you I didn't spend the time but
if you spend the time to move the matrix
multiplications into the GPU it's gonna
be even faster especially in the browser
so no js' uses the same core as the
Chrome browser so it is as performant as
the browser or the browser is performed
as nodejs so you can already do live
transcription of your brain as we saw it
in the browser as well and it's gonna
work okay ah one more there please
those are very dark waters but yes
anything is possible and unfortunately
to be completely honest I also fear that
this tag will go into wrong hands
and if surveillance government forces
you to use this tag against the the
citizens it's going to be a nightmare
so it's actually can be used as a weapon
as well please to parse your memories
and whatever you see so that's you know
think about somebody embedding an
electrode in your brain and then they
get live feed of whatever you see and
you cannot turn it off and it takes your
body's power to function so you cannot
also plug the power it's very very this
topic but sorry for for bringing down
the mood but yeah there are a lot of
applications most of them are very
dangerous
any other questions one more okay this
is the last one please pushing data to
the brain yes
it's theoretically possible not at this
level obviously but people claim to do
in interesting things but it's also very
very dangerous for health you can
instantly kill somebody and that's
that's not another good way but yeah
it's theoretically possible so thank you
everybody for coming today and for
listening to me I hope you have a great
conference
Thanks